et davanture cela sortira mercredi
prochain sur les écrans français
en attendant voici un petit aperçu avec
transforce à la poursuite du diamant
vert ayant battu les records mondiaux de
recettes ces héros kathleen turner et
michael douglas ont remis ça évidemment
cascades baiser bagarre explosion que
prévu mais au lieu de s'agiter sous les
pluies d'amérique ce couple infernal
opère sous le soleil d'afrique apprécié
malgré ses coûts et ses boss michael
douglas à la fois star et producteur est
pourtant vrai comme l'oeil double ronge
double effort mais le rôle vous est-il
jean cocteau
c'est quoi le meilleur est derrière la
caméra
alors si on vous disait maintenant il
faudra choisir où vous êtes producteur
pour tout le reste de votre vie où vous
êtes acteur vous choisiriez quoi mais ce
n'est pas la socia pour moi fait le
choix mais il faut détonateur parce que
quand on est honnête on était adolescent
alors pour le moment
par exemple quand je suis sur le terrain
je pense m'en a traversé les vaillants
ça c'est seulement le situation et
j'oublie tous les autres problèmes et
j'aime beaucoup faire les actions parce
que pour cette raison j'ai une fille ce
qui à cette marotte joie de l'illégal
son travail qu'est ce que je fais je
cours je prends une fusi comme bang bang
mon fils m'a dit mais à part ça c'est et
j'ai fait la même chose dans le pack
chaque jour après l'école et tu es payé
pour ça qu'elle affecte ses miss vous
paye enfin troisième rôle michael est
devenu chanteur pour le clip du diamant
du nil